Chancellor Merkel discussed the issue
with polish Prime Minister Donald Tusk
she went over the situation in phone
conversations with other heads of state
as well Merkel said Russia had failed to
fully implement an agreement to
de-escalate the Ukraine crisis horseland
Hut Russia has the power or would have
the power to bring the separatists on to
a peaceful path of discussion about the
Constitution and preparations for
elections big they are this was your
nerd ever unfortunately no such action
has been taken later oscar g the
international community is still hoping
for a diplomatic solution but it has
threatened to impose further sanctions
on Russia after talks with South Korean
leader Park when Hugh US President
Barack Obama indicated Washington was
paving the way for sanctions aimed at
specific parts of Russia's economy
what's also important is laying the
groundwork so that if and when we see
even greater escalation perhaps even
military incursion by Russia into
Ukraine that were prepared for the sort
of sectoral sanctions that would have
even larger consequences the so-called
Eastern Partnership of EU states and
Eastern European nations also called on
Russia to take action to calm the
situation for the roads there is a
unanimous recommendation to the Russian
Federation that it as a peaceful gesture
with the aim of de-escalating the
russia-ukraine conflict pulls its forces
from the Ukrainian border as tensions
continue to rise the likelihood of an
implementation of the Geneva agreement
to resolve the conflict is getting
fainter